patients who are using medicinal
marijuana for pain and other chronic
symptoms are getting turned down by
insurers right now even in states where
medicinal marijuana is legal insurer's
are basically reluctant to cover it
because of conflicting laws because as
far as the FDA is concerned because it's
the Federal Drug Administration
medicinal marijuana is not legal so now
we have people with cancer and AIDS and
all kinds of other drugs that are due
finding something that is helping them
and helping them deal with pain and now
again we have the federal government
coming in and stopping the insurers from
allowing these people to medicate
themselves
this to me this is like the worst of the
worst well I got the impression that it
was the insurance companies choosing not
to well it is but it's because it's yeah
and because of that legal limbo it's
understandable that a big company would
not want to step in the middle of that
until it's actually figured out whether
or not you know they are assisting in
the commission of a crime by covering it
with insurance versus not thank you for
that what I would say is you know duh
insurance companies never really do want
to add coverage for things that means
they have to pay out more money they're
not interested in that so I can see them
also saying I will just wait cuz you
know that means that we have to put out
more money for something and we're not
gonna do that if I don't have to right
so like everything does this just come
down to money because to me the FDA
loves everything in pill form and when
you have everything in pill form there's
also three minutes of diarrhea and
possible suicide and death and all that
others it comes with every one of those
cars you know all the people dancing and
they're happy but they're also having
diarrhea and death and all that kinda
stuff yes and thought to suicide they
were inevitable yeah so is this
partially because marijuana just doesn't
have its we don't have a pill yet we
don't have just that perfect pill and
also that when they when it comes out
one day which it will it's not gonna
have all those side effects because we
doesn't have those items yeah so is this
just like a failure of our system at the
highest side-effects I don't know I mean
it depends on who you talk to how much
you use you know for sure I've never
been with anyone who's smoking weed and
suddenly had horrible dad
you were lucky sir let me tell you
that's a good week yeah in Indiana our
wheat isn't that good yeah you know
what's gonna happen usually got laced
with some kind of like you know
benzodiazepine or so which the FDA is
totally for but that a real thing it
sounds real might as well be it would be
something that would give you exactly
there's something that starts with benzo
that the FDA is yes benzoyl it's a car
oil motor oil well okay yes it is money
and it does come down to money was that
your question yeah I remember who's
spending a thousand dollars a month on
weed so yeah if you're very sick you
could I know I saw this in that in that
sense like I know a guy who can cut that
in half for you because you can he'll
give you as much as you ever want but
like that seems like a very large amount
even to the point if you were trying to
medicate every day yeah I don't want to
get caught in the semantics you know but
we're let's talk about you know if you
are somebody who is truly disabled by
some kind of condition that makes it so
you can't work then yeah you're gonna be
on disability which pays very little and
then the only medication that gives you
any relief is something that's not
covered I mean I can understand it does
put people who are poor because of their
disability into a huge bind you know I
don't know I don't know how we solve
that particular problem because
personally I'm not sure it's a good idea
to get the FDA involved in studying and
testing and approving marijuana because
we've seen what they do with the
pharmaceutical industry and we see I
just I just wanna where do you see that
going because if they do I see it could
turning into pill form I see it you know
losing its effectiveness I see it being
a controlled market and that means that
big pharmaceuticals roll companies will
take over and then it kind of ruins it
for everybody because we've seen what
happens with everything when the suits
get in right so okay so I'm on board
that so then what do we do related to
insurance then so that's that that's no
maybe there's a way for the for the
federal government to end the legal
limbo aspect and say okay if you're in a
state that has decided to allow for
recreational or medicinal marijuana if
you're in a state that does that then we
are not going to prosecute you and give
insurance companies direct and specific
legal guidance the
they can offer that without themselves
getting into some kind of you know
accessory related crime right which
going back to the previous story that
seems to be in line with the thinking of
what Obama and holder should meet really
why don't they just don't seem to be
doing it so so I just think that as far
as the the drug companies go those do
you need to be the people who step up
and make an actually effective product
because for all of the people who are
yeah but you know it's another
opportunity for them to do something
right they're not all horrible I mean
they make a lot of really good things
that help a lot of really sick people
you know and I think that they they
obviously wouldn't exist if they were
killing everybody with diarrhea and and
time and I I just want you know I think
that as we go forth it will obviously
you know like I said before it's just
something that's sort of caught in this
weird gray area right now yeah we're
working through I think these issues
what I think one thing that could be
done is when people make sure that they
tell their representatives at the local
state and national level we want to make
this legal and we want to end this legal
limbo and Congress has the power to do
that more so I think then Obama with
executive actions he can only do so much
but if it's built into the law you know
if we demand that of our representatives
you know it party there is a possibility
that it could happen so to get us to get
us to demand that do we need like a
George Clooney to jump on board we'd
think publicly instead of it seems like
we talked about weed and everyone you go
to the easy jokes I get it you know we
talked we could go to Snoop Dogg and
Willie Nelson me and woody house and do
we need someone like a Clooney to to
literally get sick and then be like this
is how I'm helping myself and that that
would be the thing that would get people
to realize how screwed up the system is
I think that would help you know I don't
know but I having having a look at me
like you're like just I don't think he
has to get sick I would prefer it not
that way that it's a this is a this is a
civil libertarian issue and we can all
basically say get the government out of
this particular out of our lives in this
particular area you know and just move
forward with that you know maybe having
a famous spokesperson a celebrity
spokesperson would would be the trick to
help
Alvin eyes people to tell the
representatives but you know it's it's
taken a long time to even get to the
point where we are now where we have
break that's all and Eli's yeah I know I
I don't know there you go
I know whatever generic name look I just
I think that I think celebrities doing
things that are political I hate so much
anyway that it's like it's just it's an
eye roller for me as you know somebody
who doesn't watch TMZ every single day
right so I don't know so it would be
ineffective but for me it but I my
mind's already made up so maybe I'm not
a really good person to act